hey everybody this is David Petty I'm a
chess expert here for the chess calm
YouTube channel and today I want to talk
about the four-move checkmate
which is also called scholars mate now
if you are ever a kid who played chess
or if you have kids who play chess you
know exactly what I'm talking about this
checkmate happens millions of times
every year especially in scholastic
chess and also in beginner chess and
it's a way for white to make a quick and
deadly checkmating attack against the
black king by coordinating his pieces
against a weak square now in chess it's
always a good idea to keep your eyes
peeled for weak spots in your enemy camp
and you know in your own camps you can
defend them now if you were to look at
these three squares in front of the
black King which one would you think is
a weakness think about that which one is
weak and which ones are strong the
answer is the weak square is f7 and let
me just demonstrate why the other two
points are strong let's say that white
quickly jumps out with this Queen comes
over here and says checkmate attacking
d7 here this is not only not a checkmate
it's a terrible plan because there are
several different black pieces all
defending this d7 square see if you can
count them all how many pieces are
guarding that square well the answer is
one two three four pieces are all
defending that square that's like the
least safe square on the board for
whites pieces if you go there you're
going to get obliterated right likewise
if you jump out quickly and make a run
over here at E seven charge checkmate
how many different black pieces are
guarding that square once again it is
one two
three four pieces are all guarding that
square so these two squares D seven and
E 754 me however F seven is a very good
target because how many pieces are
defending that square that's right only
one only the king is defending that
square so that's a place from which you
can attack the king and not a lot of
blacks army is defending it so there's a
lot of chess openings that are sort of
designed to strike at this weak point in
blacks position quickly and scholars
made the four-move checkmate is one of
them now notice that this pawn is on a
light square so white plays pawn to e4
releasing his bishop and is queen
primarily and notice that they both move
on light squares right so if black is
just playing carelessly we can have a
game and very quickly like this first
the bishop comes out shooting at this
weak square now the Queen comes out and
if black is not careful he just jumps
out here tries to chase the Queen away
but unfortunately she's not going
backwards she's going forward Queen
takes pawn checkmate right the King
can't take the Queen because the bishop
is providing backup and the King has
nowhere to run because of the Queen
guarding all those squares so this is
the form of checkmate
you can similarly reach that same
position by switching your move order
you can bring out your Queen first and
then you hop out with your bishop and
once again if black does not notice and
defend himself he can get checkmated
very very quickly and I told you already
thousands and millions of games every
year are finished just like this with
this form of checkmate now I know this
seems really basic but from this very
short and quick game we can actually
learn several important points of chess
strategy and the first thing we learn is
a
out keeping your eyes open keeping your
eyes peeled and finding those weaknesses
right so at the start of the game white
didn't just kind of develop his pieces
without a plan he looked around and said
aha there is a weak point and every
single move that white made from move
one on was devoted to targeting that
weak point turning the weak point into a
target forest pieces and the second
thing we learn is how to coordinate
pieces together notice that white brings
out this bishop to aim at the f7 pawn
and then he brings out the Queen and
this is called coordinating your pieces
when your pieces are both working
together towards a goal and in chess
even if both sides have all of their
pieces developed and fighting the side
that has the better piece coordination
will usually be the winning side so
there are different types of piece
coordination but here's one of them
choosing a target square and then aiming
your whole army in this case two pieces
but you can imagine aiming three or four
pieces at that square right now the
third thing we learn is actually defense
right
so black didn't have to sit here
helplessly while white was coming out
here to attack the square of doom in
this position on move to black can
already kind of smell that something is
coming if your alert and you can right
here stop
scholars mate for good shut it down how
would black do that
how could you prevent scholars made
before it even begins to brew very good
you can imagine that the Queen is going
to come out to either this h5 Square to
aim at f7 or this f3 Square to aim at f7
and both of those moves can be stopped
by one nice natural developing move and
that is the move Knight f6 the Queen can
no longer come out to h5 because we will
simply take her so we stopped that and
if the Queen comes out to f3 well that
no longer makes much sense because the
knight is blocking the path right so
if they try to scholars make you by
playing efore ee5 and then Bishop c4 you
can just stop it before it even starts
with the move Knight f6 however what if
they go the other way
efore g5 and Queen to h5 well this is
actually going to demonstrate to us why
while scholars mate is a deadly and
sometimes effective opening attack it's
not something you want to do yourself
once you get to a certain level and the
reason is this there's an opening
principle that I didn't actually mention
in my previous video on the phases of
the game but there's an opening
principle it says don't bring your queen
out too early if you ever saw the movie
searching for Bobby Fischer right with
Josh Waitzkin as a little kid you
remember he was always arguing with his
coach pandolfini pandolfini kept telling
him stop bringing your Queen out too
early and he kept doing it and kind of
getting away with it but in general you
don't want to bring your queen out too
early because she's your most valuable
piece and she's going to get targeted by
the other pieces right you're not
willing to trade your queen for pretty
much anything except another Queen
unless you're getting a whole bunch of
pieces for her so you can't just target
her right away because then she comes
over here and takes your pawn and you're
down upon for nothing so first you're
going to have to defend your ePHI pawn
and what do you think the best way is to
do that exactly Knight to c6 bringing
out a piece and defending the pawn at
the same time now here comes scholars
made Bishop to c4 if you are not careful
you're about to lose right and black has
several ways to defend so why don't you
pause for a second and think how would
you try to get out of this checkmate
right if you don't do anything you're a
goner how do you defend now you could
defend by guarding the f7 Square and
extra time right White has two attackers
you have one defender if you add a
second defender then you'll be safe so a
move like Queen e7 or Queen f6 would
defend this f7 point but though
are the most principled of moves because
if you play queenie seven you're kind of
matching white sort of breaking of
principles bringing their own queen out
too early by bringing your queen out too
early too and notice that you're
blocking in your bishop and making it
harder to develop your army likewise if
you play Queen f6 you're once again
bringing your own queen out too early
she can be quickly targeted by pieces
and you're blocking your knight from its
best and most natural square Knight f6
so both of those moves will stop
scholars mate but they're kind of subpar
the best move is to realize that white
is breaking a principle by bringing
their Queen out too early and you want
to go on the offensive and start chasing
that Queen around and punishing her from
coming out where your pieces can attack
her you play g6 and now they can't
checkmate you because Queens can't jump
and you're attacking the Queen so the
best move for white is probably just to
slink back to d1 and admit that the
Queen shouldn't have come out too early
but let's say that white continues
trying to checkmate you remember this f3
Square is another route that the Queen
can take to get here well now you once
again stop the scholars made by
naturally developing your pieces Knight
to f6 you can't take the knight because
the Queen is guarding it and now white
is just sitting here they move the Queen
twice and you're about to get attacked
by black's knight you could once again
swing over here to b3 and target f7
again right just never giving up on your
plan but this is going to end in tears
for white and let's see if you can think
of what black should do here pause your
video and give it a good thing all right
the best move for black is to realize
that checkmate is actually no longer
being threatened because with the bishop
coming here to f7
the King will have the e7 Square so
black says okay fine
you can take me and just jumps here to
d4 and attacks the Queen right and
you're continuing to punish the Queen
for coming out too early now if black
gets greedy
and takes here on f7 check for a moment
you know whites dream has come true but
the black King simply moves forward and
suddenly white is in a double attack the
bishop is under attack the Queen is
under attack if you move the Queen just
anywhere the King takes the bishop and
white is down a bishop for nothing for
no compensation really so instead white
has to play the move Queen to see for
finding a safe place for the Queen that
maintains this defense of the bishop and
that's the only square that does it and
black here plays another move that it
first looks a little bit bizarre but it
makes perfect sense when you think about
it black plays b5 attacking the Queen
again and taking away every single
square the Queen has to guard this
Bishop right now the Queen has to move
off of this diagonal and the King takes
the bishop for free and this is already
winning for black but let's just look at
one or two more moves to see what could
happen let's say that white notices his
pawn here is under attack and he plays
the natural looking move pawn to d3 to
defend his pawn and releases bishop now
because this Queen came out too early
black can win the Queen with a to move
tactic so see if you can find it very
good the sequence Bishop b4 chat
complains to the King with a fabulous
night for this is a family fork hitting
the king check the Queen hello and the
rook in the corner when the King moves
you pick up a queen Black is up a whole
Queen for nothing and it's because white
sort of stubbornly insisted on going
after this square of doom this weakest
Square no matter what with their Queen
coming out too early and it turns out
that if black is fully prepared for this
and plays actively that white actually
gets in trouble if you just defend your
pond and then when the bishop comes out
you chase the Queen around get out of
here she comes back here you keep
developing your army if the Queen
insists on moving over
and over again finally this move is
going to put white in a lot of trouble
and black will take over the initiative
and possibly win some material so I hope
that lesson was useful for you and never
fall victim to the four-move checkmate
again I hope you enjoyed this video and
I'll see you around on chess calm